الى العراق هناك جدل اثره اعلان للاتحاد
العراقي لكمال الاجسام رفض اشراك النساء
في اللعبه سواء داخل البلاد او المشاركه
في المسابقات الخارجيه بالفعل هذا الاعلان
الخرجه بحجه ان اللعبه تخالف العادات
وتقاليد واعراض المجتمع المحافظ فاذا عبد
الحسن او عفوا فائز عبد الحسن رئيس
الاتحاد قال انه يفضل ان تمارس النساء هذه
اللعبه بغرض الحفاظ على الرشاقه لا بغرض
المشاركه في البطوله والاتحاد يرى ان
اللعبه مخصصه للرجال
حسره عال اضطرت اللاعبات المشاركه او الى
المشاركه في اي بطوله فيجب ان تكون
البطوله للسيدات فقط وباشراف كادر نسوي
المزيد دائما مع زينب المشاط العراق
[موسيقى]
لا ديننا ولا عادتنا ولا تقاليدنا تسمح
للمراه العراقيه بالمشاركه في المسابقه
الخاصه باللعبه والتي ينظمها الاتحاد
الاسيوي والدولي هذا التصريح قاله رئيس
الاتحاد العراقي لبناء الاجسام والذي لقى
غضبا كبيرا من قبل النساء والراي العام
للنسوي
الاتحاد يجد ان العادات والتقاليد اسمى من
بطولاته بناء الاجسام وان الدين يمنع ذلك
ايضا وان النساء الراغبات بالمشاركه في
هذه البطولات عليهن ان يشاركنا في بطولات
النسويه وباشراك كادر نسوي
لعباتهم كثر عبرنا عن غضبهن فبعضهن على
مجهوزيتهن للمشاركه في هذه اللعبه وفي
بطولات خارجيه هذا العام لكن هذا التصريح
خذلهن ونشطات على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وجدنا ان هذا المنع يندرج ضمن منهجيه
قائمه على التمييز لكن رئيس الاتحاد يجب
ان من حق المراه ممارسته هذه اللعبه لكن
للحصول على قواما رشيق وقوي وسليم زينب
صباح العربيه بغداد
بغداد تنضم الينا اللاعب زينه علي زينه
صباح الخير
صباح
الخير صباح النور عليكم على كل المشاهدين
جميعا اهلا وسهلا ليش زعلانين على فائز
عبد الحسن يعني الرجل قال هذا الموقف ويجب
ان تقف ولا تشارك المراه العراقيه او حتى
تلعب هذه الرياضه مو الكم
نحن كنساء او او ناشطات او لاعبات مختصات
او مهتمات بالجانب الرياضي طبعا احنا ضد
هذا القرار
قرار تمييزه طبعا قرار تمييزي رياضه
مبدئيا صحه عامه للجسم تعتبر علاج طبيعي
قوه عضليه تحسين الصحه العامه
محافظه على الجسم من الامراض المزمنه ممكن
امراض القلب وغيرها والسكري
تحسين مزاج عموما
زينه هو يعني التصريح كان لا يتحدث عن انه
النساء لا يجب ان يلعبن الرياضه لا وكان
بيتحدث عن نقطه معينه
العبوا رياضه قد ما بدكم ولكن يتحدث عن
نقطه معينه وهي المشاركه في مسابقات دوليه
اللي ممكن
بعتقد انه اللبس عاده بيكون منافي للعادات
والتقاليد المحافظه العربيه
فهذه هي النقطه كيف تعلقين على هذا
الموضوع المشاركه في بطولات دوليه تحديدا
الموضوع لا مشكله به
[موسيقى]
الشعب او المجتمع الشرقي تحديدا
بعده طوائف وكل طائفه تلزمها عاده وتقاليد
من الممكن انه يفرض الاتحاد الدولي يفرض
على اللاعب انه المشاركه واللاعبه طيب
زينه يعني
اليوم مرعب ممكن تشيل البيت تشيل اسره بس
رايحه النادي شايلات لي 200 كيلو
لا يعني شلون ماكو مشكله قاعد يقول لك انه
والله لا تدخلين بطولات هذا البطولات
رجالي يحكمون فيها وانت شايله هذا الثقل
او بناء حتى بناء الاجسام فبالتالي
استعراض هذا الجسم وعضلاته
يقول مو مقبوله
لا منطق لعادات لا تقاليد واحنا نطالب
بالمساواه بين المراه والرجل كيف نميزه
وانا عنصر الرياضه هاي تحديدا حدث هاي
للنساء للرجال ما ما تصير شلون ما تصير
الرجل قاعد يقول انه اذا كان كمال الاجسام
فهو ما زال مجتمعيا مرفوض
ولا مقبول بالعراق
لا الى مقبوليه بالعراق
انا تحديدا من يعني تشوفين مثلا
عند المراه العراقيه وتمشي بالشارع
اني من فتره مهتمه بهاي الرياضه تحديدا
وان شاء الله الايام المقبله اكو فرق كبير
انت شركتي
اني ما شاركت بطولات كمال اجسام نشاركت
بطولات ولعبت بعده انديه كره قدم
هواها رياضي بامتياز
يا زينه قبل لا تشكرينها بس زينه خليني
اقول لك انه رفع الاثقال موجود يعني الدول
المحيطه بالعراق تشارك فيه وحتى في بطولات
بالاولمبياد ايضا هي موجوده ربما ايضا قد
ناخذ راي السيد فائز عبد الحسن في حلقه
قادمه ونشوف ليش شكرا جزيلا زينه شكرا
زينه علي لاعبه بناء لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات التقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات